were the horrendous acts committed me 10
times the number of people sitting in
this room now were murdered he's correct
10 times the amount of people in that
audience were killed by
Israel from black resin I do
bodybuilding boxing calisthenics I run
out of energy gillit is a natural
substance found in the Himalayas created
by centuries of grass and organisms
decomposing into a thick black goop
which makes it very potent it's like a
tart likee you just get a little bit of
this onto the spoon so you can get hot
water not too hot inshallah so it can
disintegrate into the water also there
is some studies that show it boosts
testesterone even helps the respiratory
system as well bu yours now brother
sisters go to the description box in and
use my discount code let's see stronger
better more focused Muslim men who are
serving their lord and their families
and their wives and their children in
I'm going to show you guys in step by
step how to cancel your pure genocidal
pure gym membership inshallah here is
what the CEO had to say you can't really
make this up guys in look look at look
at the at the example he gives to why
the war started let's hear it for
ourselves inshallah where horrendous
acts committed mean 10 times the number
of people sitting in this room now were
murdered on the October the 7th in Cold
Blood and double the number of people
sitting in this room were taken into
Gaza as hostages and the number of
people in this room as we sit here today
are still held as hostages and that's
the precursor uh to what happened to
what's happening there today I'm deeply
concerned he's correct 10 times the
amount of people in that audience were
killed by Israel and I'm not making this
stuff up it was said by haret let's read
it for
oursel haret
said Israeli official investigation
concluded that an Israeli military
helicopter
killed re rers revealers whatever
they're called uh the these party goers
at the Nava on 7 October and that Hamas
did not even know about the festival who
was this from Harris
so he's correct they were killed they
were massacred they were murdered just
like they're doing in Palestine by the
Israeli government theirself their
attack in uh their um Attack Helicopters
is the reason why they were massacred
that amount of people were killed now
you can't make this stuff up the the
fact that they think the war started on
7th of October which we know this is
something going far far far far long
time ago if their argument is that they
are justified in doing what they're
doing 7th of October then to their logic
we should be like that Hamas is
Justified of doing anything and
everything based on all the stuff that
they've been putting the Palestinians
through for the past 70 80 years that's
their logic anyways now pure gym B say I
left pure gym long time ago nothing to
do with this um I went to my local gy
aldah big nasty gym alhamdulillah even
it gives me good reminders like you know
Ramadan went well brothers and sisters
ID stay away from Shayan come on here
you go stay away from the Shan aldah at
least big nasty aldah gives me some good
reminders at his gym that's where I go
go to your local gyms guys this is how
you can cancel your membership I want to
make it quick swiftly and to the point
inah make sure brother sisters that you
we have the power now Starbucks
McDonald's Coca-Cola these companies
boycott them BR says we have the power
and they are frightened alhamdulillah
the whole world has seen the face the
mask drop off in the whole Western World
the Zionism I just want to thank Israel
we could have not done it without you if
I had billions of pound and spent on
movies to do this I would be able to
convince the people the way you guys
have done it for us so thank you very
much carry on carry on you're doing our
job for us brilliant the whole entire
Globe from universities America to here
and the entire nations have seen your
face and how barbaric you guys are by
cting your texture here's a video of one
of our brothers on Tik Tok who's going
to show you a stepbystep guide to block
your P gym membership inah and funnily
enough I went to the app today cuz I was
a member before and it says this message
it says error I wonder why that error is
popping off I wonder is there a lot of
people started to cancel the memberships
cancel your memberships and go to your
local gyms guys alhamdulillah it is much
much better alhamdulillah brothers and
sisters that's all I'm going to say
inshallah may Allah bless and preserve
you guys we have the power and pure gy
will know that it is nothing but pure
genocide that's been committed by the
Zionist may Allah destroy them and like
Allah says in the Quran do not ever
Allah is unaware of what the evildoers
do he only delays them for a day that
their eyes will stare in horror and we
will witness those days and we will
witness that day when they will be
staring in horror cancel your membership
now you're trying to cancel your pure
gym membership because of the CEO
comment that he made regarding razza on
question time last night and you can't
do it in the app follow these
instructions go to the desktop version
and click your gym membership then go to
your gym and click manage then freeze or
cancel your membership and click manage
then click this cancel my contract free
membership then over here give him the
reason let them know what the CEO was up
to on question time last night and hit
cancel and just like that your
membership will be successfully canceled